the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
Theory video today I want to discuss one
of my favorite characters from the books
which is the red woman also known as
Melisandre this is a character I have
made many videos about before but in
this video I want to discuss an idea
that some of you may have never
considered before I want to talk about
one of the reasons I believe Melisandre
hides her identity now in the Game of
Thrones television series we were shown
that Melisandre hides her identity
because she was hundreds of years old
but I think there may be another reason
why she does this in the books
I believe Melisandre may have been
resurrected from the dead just like many
other characters within a Song of Ice
and Fire
let me show you some of the evidence
that leads me to this belief then you
can give me your opinions at the end of
the video shall we begin the first thing
I want to do is read something George RR
Martin's said about his resurrected
characters during an interview George
said if someone comes back from the dead
especially if they suffer a violent
traumatic death they're not gonna come
back as nice as ever that's what I was
trying to do and I'm still trying to do
with the Lady Stoneheart character in
poor beric Dondarrion who was set up as
the foreshadowing for all this every
time he's a little less beric his
memories are fading he's got all these
scars he's becoming more and more
physically hideous because he's not a
living human being anymore his heart
isn't beating his blood isn't flowing in
his veins he's a white but a white
animated by fire instead of by ice now
we're getting back to the whole Ice and
Fire thing now of course all of us were
already familiar with whites because
they made up the majority of the night
Kings army but as you can see George our
Martin did confirm Lady Stoneheart and
beric Dondarrion our whites as well the
only difference is the night Kings
whites are ice whites reanimated by the
great other whereas Lady Stoneheart and
beric Dondarrion are Fire whites
reanimated by real or ice whites and
fire why
do have some things in common although
they are two opposing forces there is
one other resurrected character from the
books that I want to reference in the
video and that is cold hands the
mysterious man from beyond the wall
thankfully brain stark was able to spend
some time with cold hands which gave us
some insight into how this character's
body functions one thing that is very
obvious is once a character is
resurrected from the dead their bodies
no longer function the same way they
used to and I think the same thing can
be said for Melisandre each of these
reanimated characters has some very
interesting similarities to Melisandre
which is what I want to go over next
let's look at some of the text from the
books because I believe it may indicate
that Melisandre was also reanimated by
real or something we already know she
has a very close connection to one of
the first things I noticed in the books
is how none of these characters seem to
need to sleep any more now that they've
been brought back from the dead this is
something brain stark notices while
traveling with cold hands to blood
Ravens cave this is what it says in
brain Starks chapter bran had been
afraid to speak of it but he had noticed
whenever they took shelter for the night
while he and Hodor in the reeds huddled
together for warmth the Ranger kept
apart sometimes cold hands closed his
eyes but brain did not think he would
sleep so as you can see it does not
appear as if cold hands needs to sleep
anymore
ever since getting brought back from the
dead now let's look at what Arya Stark
notices about beric Dondarrion this is
what it says in arias chapter he did not
seem to sleep either his good I would
often close as if from weariness but
when you spoke to him it would flick
open again at once so it even looks like
barrack no longer needs to sleep either
ever since he was resurrected now let's
look and see what it says about Lady
Stoneheart
we learn of this during one of brianne's
chapters while she is with the
Brotherhood without banners this is what
it says she returned while we were
sleeping she never sleeps herself okay
so now we have some good evidence that
cold hands
beric Dondarrion and Lady Stoneheart no
longer need to sleep like they once did
when they were alive and well now let's
see what it says about Melisandre
sleeping habits we actually learn about
this and Melisandre is very own POV
chapter this is what it says she was
thinking
dawn another day has given us whirl or
be praised the terrors of the night
recede
Melisandre has spent the night in her
chair by the fire as she often did with
a stain is gone her bed saw little use
she had no time for sleep
with the weight of the world upon her
shoulders and she feared to dream sleep
is a little death dreams the whisperings
of the other who would drag us all into
his eternal night some nights she
drowsed but never for more than an hour
one day
Melisandre prayed she would not sleep at
all so as you can see this sounds very
similar to what we read about cold hands
and beric Dondarrion their eyes will
close briefly but they aren't actually
sleeping now let's go ahead and take
another look at a connection between
these characters another thing brain
stark notices about cold hands is he
never actually needs to drink or eat any
food this is what it says in brains
chapter he hides his face and will not
speak a name who is he what is he anyone
can put on a black cloak anyone or
anything he does not eat he never drinks
he does not seem to feel the cold the
Ranger killed a pig cold hands stood
beside the door a raven on his arm both
staring at the fire reflections from the
flames glittered all four black eyes he
does not eat bran remembered and he
fears the flames so right here you can
see that bran noticed his coat hands
does not need to eat any food which does
make sense because he's not a living
human being anymore
Arya Stark also happens to notice the
very same thing about bearing dog Marian
this is what it says in arias chapter
Lord beric himself did not eat Arya had
never seen him eat though from time to
time he took a cup of wine since beric
Dondarrion has been resurrected he no
longer needs to eat any food either now
let's see what it says about Melisandre
this is what she thinks in her POV
chapter does milady wish to break her
fast ask Devin food yes I should eat
someday she forgot real or provided her
with all the nourishment her body needed
but that was something best concealed
from mortal men this is one of the more
interesting quotes I wanted to show you
because I think it could reveal a few
different things
once again Melisandre has character
ristic sound very similar to the other
resurrected characters in the story she
doesn't need to sleep and she doesn't
need to eat any food
she only reminds herself to eat so that
it doesn't alarm some of the other
characters around her she doesn't want
them to know certain things about her
now what's interesting is when
Melisandre thinks to herself she refers
to everyone else as mortal men I think
this is some strong evidence that she's
not a living human being like most of
the other characters and that's because
she doesn't think of herself as the same
because she's not the same like she said
well or provides her with all the
nourishment her body needs similar at
the beric Dondarrion and Lady Stoneheart
which is why they don't sleep or eat any
food either now just in case this isn't
enough evidence to sway you one way or
the other
let's go ahead and look at some other
interesting details about the characters
they have some more connections that
lead me to believe Melisandre has been
resurrected as well another thing these
characters have in common is the colour
of their blood in another one of Arya
Starks chapters we learned the color of
beric Dondarrion blood while he's
fighting Sandor Clegane this is what it
says
Arya shrieked but the burning sword
snapped in two in the hounds cold steel
plowed into Lord beric's flesh where his
shoulder joined his neck and clothed him
cleaned down to the breastbone the blood
came rushing out in a hot black gush so
right here we can see the baritone
darienne's blood is described as being
black instead of red his blood came
rushing out in a hot black gush now
let's see what it says about Lady
Stoneheart sblood in the epilogue of a
Storm of Swords it says this half her
hair was gone and the rest had turned as
white and brittle as a Crone's beneath
her ravaged scalp
her face was shredded skin and black
blood where she had raped herself with
her nails this is another instance of a
character resurrected by real or who has
black blood now let's see what it says
about Melisandre is blood we find out
this information and went to Davos his
chapters while Melisandre is giving
birth to the shadow baby this is what it
says here she squatted and spread her
legs blood rained down her thighs black
is ink
you see Melisandre is known as the red
woman she wears red her hair is red and
even her eyes are red but her blood is
black his
I think this is because she is no longer
a living character or else her blood
would be red like everything else about
her
we know Melisandre hid herself in this
show because of her age but could there
be another reason why she conceals her
true identity we don't have a whole
bunch of information about these
reanimated characters but we do know
they all seem to share some of the same
characteristics they no longer need to
sleep drink or eat any food because like
Melisandre said we're lore provides them
with all the nourishment they need the
books have yet to reveal what happens to
Melisandre when she removes her necklace
but I would not be surprised if we find
out she is just as hideous as Lady
Stoneheart or beric Dondarrion leave me
some of your thoughts down below I'd
like to see what some of you have to say
about this anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching the video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone for supporting the channel I
hope you all have a great day I'll see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]